the successful societies program was
established ten years ago and has
brought together a highly
interdisciplinary group of people to
have a conversation together about how
to make societies better places one of
the strengths of our group now is that
we've worked together for 10 years
and i think we're we've developed a
remarkable capacity to understand or to
to function a little bit like a
multi-headed hydra
it's quite unusual for social scientists
from as many different
specialties
as are represented in this book or in
the program to get together and have
sustained conversations we have you know
we have historians political scientists
philosophers
economists
people in public health etc etc
psychology so one of the first things
that our project did that became this
book was to try and make a clearer um
understanding and
a better uh classification of the
elements of neoliberalism and so our our
task was first of all to get a clearer
assessment of what actually changed
uh and what didn't change what what were
the continuities as well as the changes
and then to and then to explore what
were some of the effects of those
changes it may lead people to look at
neoliberalism in a different way
and
i would say in a more optimistic way
there's a number of other
values that drives human being besides
profit maximization and this is the kind
of questions that i think we're
particularly well equipped to address
well we hope that
many
scholars and students and members of the
general public will find in this book
a better way of understanding some of
the more most basic features of their
lives
as as those lives are lived in the midst
of
neoliberal reforms neoliberal ideas what
makes it possible for
a community or even a nation
to absorb some kind of environmental or
economic shock and then come out the
other side stronger than they went in
you